buenos días la gran preocupación entre
la población en este momento es que por
segundo año se cancelen las fiestas de
navidad porque desde el verano estamos
viviendo aquí en el reino unido- un tipo
de nueva normalidad así que el gobierno
ha anunciado un paquete de medidas para
tratar de demorar lo que más pueda la
propagación masiva de esta variante o
micro aunque ya está presente en este
país se ha reportado hasta el momento
nueve casos seis de ellos en escocia y
tres en inglaterra estas medidas
incluyen el regreso de el tapabocas
obligatorio en los comercios en el
transporte público habrá booster una
tercera dosis de refuerzo para todas las
edades a partir de los 18 años
probablemente los niños entre los 12 y
los 15 años se les ofrecerá una segunda
dosis además todos los viajeros a partir
de este martes a las 4 de la mañana
tendrán que hacerse una prueba pcr
cuando termine el segundo día de su
estadía aquí en el reino unido- y sólo
podrán abandonar es el lugar donde están
haciendo esa cuarentena si dan negativo
también habrá restricciones como ya lo
reportando a lo largo del fin de semana
con 10 países africanos para como les
digo tratar de frenar el esparcimiento
de la propagación de esta variante
omicron aquí en el reino unido